a lifetime has passed since D-Day but
the memories are vivid
the veterans who gathered here were
young men even teenagers when they
stormed normandy's beaches now they're
back once more a dwindling band of
witnesses
Jack Quinn was there at the very start
he cherishes his memories
I'm glad to go back but I think this
Normandy spirit
is to learn
the younger generation
about him never never forget it the
names on these pillars are a reminder
that D-Day wasn't just about Victory but
also the loss of more than 20 000
service men and women under British
command
prison Macon was here too D-Day is a
memory that binds France and Britain a
profound tie that goes beyond transient
politics
we meet Stanford 98 but with the
twinkling eyes of a teenager he survived
when his ship was hit by a torpedo but
he's now aghast at what he sees but you
see Europe is at war against war zone my
okay my heart bleeds for Ukraine is a
tragedy that is unfolding in our in our
lifetime
D-Day was about loss as much as victory
tens of thousands died in the Normandy
campaign but it was the turning point of
the war it was the day that changed our
world
Adam Parsons Sky News Normandy